We're off this week but
just like cocaine Mitch
the deep state
never sleeps.
You can bet the mainstream media
will keep attacking Trump
and his allies all week long.
I predicted ten news stories
sure to come from
the lying press this week
and I'm going to
preemptively strike
each one of them
down in under 90 seconds.
Chuck clock me,
And go.
Giuliani's eyes popped
out of his skull on Hannity
and started rolling
around on the floor.
And then he got on his hands
and knees looking for them
and accidently smushed one
that was a tactical move.
Laura Ingraham
was only joking
when she cyberbullied the kids
in that burn unit.
That Thing CNN said
Trump said didn't happen.
But if it did happen it
shouldn't have gotten leaked
and if it did get leaked
you shouldn't have read it.
And if you did read it what are
you some kind of a nerd.
Tucker was just being
intellectually curious
when he invited seven members
of the KKK on a show
and then cut his own Mic
so they could do whatever
they wanted for the full hour.
Relaxwhen Tomi Loren
live streamed herself
kicking that newborn deer.
It was just a metaphor
for the forgotten man.
Judge Jeanine Pirro getting
struck by lightning four times
in a row mean
she's touched by God.
There's no way Kellyanne
could have known
that her new jacket
was made of all those
dalmations.
Mike Pence is 100 percent
comfortable with women.
He just thinks theme parks
would be safer that way.
Dana Lash did not I repeat did
not turn into a flock of ravens
and knock over that old lady
that's just fake was.
The fact that the American flag
and Ted Cruz's lawns
spontaneously burst
into flames
is not a metaphor
and has nothing to do
with all of the flowers dying
and the sound you hear
of distant babies screams.
Nailed it.
Seconds to spare.
The inefensible defendant and
the fight continues in one week.
Try to make it that long.